terms with the fact that this will be
his last game in the in the uh air
things masters
um daniel dubois trying to bring his
rook up but you look at the bar look at
what the computer says
plus 100 for white that means that
the computer sees a force checkmate a
forced win now for white
um and timor rajab he goes for it the
black king is now the target white's
rook
zooming up to the top of the board
eyeing up the black king across that top
rank
um the game is pretty much over daniel
dubov
can he find a way to survive any longer
yeah it's looking unlikely and i'm just
super impressed by rajabov there and
chess bravo sums it up for me
rajabov must have ice in his veins so
cool and calm under extreme time
pressure
i have never seen the light before and
uh i love
her it's over daniel has resigned it is
all over not only this game the
semi-final match between these two
it's over danny well he's out
timora rajavo is heading to the air
things masters final
wow i have to say i'm a little bit
surprised i didn't think that before the
tournament started but
wow how impressive is his play yeah it's
just brilliant i it's it's masterpiece
in the making
i didn't love this game you know i
didn't expect it all these
very unusual maneuvers that he made the
kind of wait and see game and then
suddenly he pounced
and that's it uh dubois was helpless and
above well we see he's uh disappointed
but
not much to read out of team urachapo
it's not easy to see if he's
probably inside david he must be so
excited